[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue à tous ici au Salon
International de l'Agriculture pour ce
dernier numéro le Mag a choisi de donner
la parole aux jeunes aux jeunes de La
Réunion qui ont fait le choix de
s'orienter vers la filière agricole ils
sont une trentaine à avoir fait le
déplacement jusqu'ici Porte de
Versailles ils sont engagés dans divers
organismes de formation fille et garçon
ils sont précieux pour la filière
agricole qui s'inquiète de son avenir de
la relève alors nous avons voulu savoir
comment est-ce qu'il se projette dans
leur future métier
Audrey Samuel romain et Patrice sont
présents sur les stands des exposants
depuis l'ouverture du salon une
expérience riche pour ces jeunes qui ont
fait le choix de mettre l'agriculture au
cœur de leur projet de vie
on va parler depuis de la culture depuis
on a
[Musique]
ans et du coup
15 hectares canne à sucre et tomates
soucis
et au début c'était pas mon domaine du
tout
mais à force de voir papa travailler
dedans
à son amour la donne envie de faire
pareil vu que les exploitations et comme
un jour si tu prends sa retraite ben il
connaît que il y a pour reprendre la
relève donc du coup
on m'a décide de l'ensemble dans
l'agriculture
moi plus tard
et pour m'acheter le fil d'avoine de
reprendre l'exploitation agricole de mes
parents
et ben quoi tu viens exploitation
par rapport à boire d'accéder au niveau
agricole
[Applaudissements]
et ma enfin il a transmis à moi
l'agriculture d'aujourd'hui
c'est de
réussir
est-ce que immortalon voit sur
l'exploitation
pour démarquer des heures
passionnant parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
choses c'est la première fois que je
viens ici donc il y a pas mal de choses
intéressantes
depuis tout petit juste deux ans et
j'aimerais bien reprendre l'exploitation
de mon père qui fait de la canne à sucre
on fait jamais la même chose
de la théorie à la pratique pour se
plonger dans le bain de ce que sera leur
futur métier les différentes
institutions et la Chambre d'Agriculture
travaillent en ce sens
c'est très formateur pour nos pour nos
apprenants c'est aussi l'occasion de
profiter du salon pour regarder un peu
ce qui se fait en termes d'innovation
on recherche beaucoup l'innovation et
donc c'est aussi capitaliser sur
des biens services de de la technologie
pour pouvoir renforcer ses compétences
et capitaliser sur ces éléments là
lorsqu'ils vont retourner en cours ou
lorsqu'ils vont débuter leur parcours à
l'installation agricole le salon de
l'agriculture qui voit passer plus de
650 000 visiteurs marquera sans aucun
doute leur parcours professionnel
le salon se poursuit jusqu'à dimanche un
marathon pour les exposants récompensés
on peut le dire par les sourires et les
impressions des visiteurs
[Musique]
des régions parce que je trouve que
c'est intéressant de découvrir un peu ce
qui se fait partout et notamment hors
métropole et je suis une fan incontestée
de chocolat et je viens de découvrir
quand vous avez du chocolat à la Réunion
et je trouve ça super et du coup avec
plein de plein de produits locaux enfin
comme il nous a expliqué l'orchidée le
sucre roux etc et je trouve ça très très
bon
l'avenir de la filière agricole c'est
l'un des enjeux de l'Odet Adobe l'office
de développement de l'économie agricole
d'outre-mer Joëlle serait-ce vous en
êtes son président bonjour Est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire l'audéadops ça
sert à quoi le mot économique de
l'agriculture ultra-marine sur des
accompagnements européens et le paiement
des aides Poséidon et des aides aussi en
relation avec le régime spécifique
agricole qui est une partie aussi des
aides européennes voilà est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire quels sont les enjeux
pour la réalité bien entendu sont très
importants pour nos territoires puisque
nous sommes à cette amont à cet un
nombre pardon vous avez la Martinique
Mayotte Guyane Guadeloupe 5e hippelon la
Réunion bien entendu mais aussi
d'autres territoires pour lesquels nous
accompagnons sur le développement de
leur agriculture et de leur méthode de
mise en valeur et de mise en production
dans l'ensemble de leur territoire voilà
la structuration des filières c'est un
enjeu la structuration des filières
s'éteint en jeu puisque le ministre de
l'Agriculture nous l'a aussi annoncé
bien que le ministre de l'Outre-mer
aussi à campagne dans ce sens donc mieux
nous sommes structurés mieux nous
pourrons affronter
y compris le marché local mais aussi sur
le marché national et est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire si pour la Réunion il y
a des objectifs chiffrés il y a un
calendrier à respecter peut-être dès
2023 alors le ministère de l'Agriculture
lance actuellement un grand programme
pour la souveraineté au niveau par
exemple les fruits et légumes et pour
nous c'est bien entendu d'arriver à 5
voir de 5% à l'horizon 2030 à 15% à
l'horizon en 2035 pour pouvoir accentuer
la production locale dans nos
territoires respectifs c'est-à-dire sur
l'ensemble du territoire
des Outre-mer mais aussi du territoire
national donc nous allons quelque part
nous aussi y contribuer en tout cas
c'est ce que nous souhaitons et c'est ce
que nous avons besoin parce que pour les
fruits et légumes c'est une des
premières que nous avons en tout cas et
nous allons accompagner ça et nos
agriculteurs attendent ça de pied ferme
en tout cas pour pouvoir faire plus
faire mieux et faire de façon digestive
merci Monsieur seresse
une image qui fait plaisir la remise des
médailles tout à l'heure au 26
agriculteurs et producteurs du village
réunion récompensés au concours général
agricole remise officielles des prix
tout à l'heure par le ministre de
l'Agriculture Marcello et puis on ne
résiste pas à l'envie de vous montrer
cette image également remise du PAT du
programme alimentaire territorial un
prix qui salue une fois encore la
qualité de cette édition pour la Réunion
nous avons été lauréat du projet
alimentaire territorial et pour la
Réunion pour le département c'est une
très belle reconnaissance puisque nous
rejoignons les 6 autres collectivités
déjà présentes dans ce dispositif à la
Réunion et le parc national dans le
coeur habité de ma femme et nous allons
maintenant fédérer cette politique des
pad à liée de la réunion nous rejoignent
également la ville de Saint-Joseph et la
commune de Saint-Paul donc on va pouvoir
maintenant travailler ensemble ce qui
est un peu le Latitude et même de notre
projet et ça qui fait ensemble comment
je pays donc on va travailler ensemble
pour pouvoir mettre la production locale
à l'honneur
le mag c'est fini merci à toutes
l'équipe qui a permis sa réalisation
merci à vous de nous avoir suivis à
bientôt